hello everybody in this video I'm going
to teach you everything you need to know
about CSS so you can turn your blind
HTML into something beautiful I will not
be covering every property or option as
CSS has to offer because there are
hundreds but I will be covering all of
the concepts you need to know in order
to get started with CSS what's first get
started with what CSS is a common
misconception is that CSS is a
programming language but that is
incorrect
CSS is actually a styling language which
is used for modifying the appearance of
the content of webpages just as hTML is
used for the content of webpages CSS is
used for presentation of that content
due to the fact that CSS is used for
presentation and design there are many
ways to do the same thing HTML on the
other hand has set elements for most
things which means that there's usually
only one correct way to do things in
HTML the ability to do things in many
different ways is the reason most people
either love or hate CSS I personally
love it since it lets you express your
creativity and gives you freedom to do
things how you want now that we
understand what CSS is let's dive into
the details of how to use CSS first we
need to discuss the syntax of CSS
luckily the syntax is straightforward
and easy to understand the first part of
the syntax is the selector there are
many different types and combinations of
selectors which we'll talk about later
but for now all you need to know is that
a CSS style starts with a selector to
apply the style to next comes an opening
and closing curly bracket that are used
to denote the start and end of the
styles that apply to the selector
everything in between these curly
brackets will be styles that are applied
to the HTML elements that match the
selector lastly inside the curly
brackets is one or more property value
pairs each of these pairs defines a
property such as color font size width
etc and a value for that property a
basic example of the CSS syntax will be
setting the text color of all h1
elements to blue now that we have the
syntax out of the way let's focus on the
various selectors CSS contains many
different types of selectors but the
main selectors are element class and ID
selectors we've already seen the element
selector in the previous example of
turning all age ones blue
any HTML element can be used as a
selector and the style is defined for
that selector will apply to all HTML
elements of that type by far the most
common and useful selector is the class
selector the class selector lets you
select HTML elements based on their
class attribute if you remember from my
HTML series all HTML elements can have
attributes assigned to them such as the
href for an anchor tag a class is just
an attribute that all HTML elements can
have and is used with CSS to distinguish
elements for specific styling the class
attribute can also have multiple
different classes in the same attribute
as long as they're separated by a space
in order to select an element by class
we need to use a period before the class
name as the CSS selector this period
tells CSS that whatever follows is a
class name and not an HTML element name
classes are the most common selector
used because they are amazing for
creating reusable components for example
if you have a site with three different
types of buttons that all share the same
basic styling but have a different color
you can use one base class of button to
define all the styles shared between all
buttons you can then have three other
classes that define the specific color
for the button then all you need to do
is add both the base button class and
your color specific class to your HTML
button element and I'll have all the
Styles defined in the base button class
and the color specific class the last
common selector is the ID selector the
ID selector is very similar to the class
selector in that it is an HTML attribute
but an element can only have one ID
while it can have multiple classes an ID
also should be unique across the entire
web page but hTML does not actually
enforce this to use an ID as a selector
you simply need to use a pound sign
followed by the ID name much like how
classes use a period followed by the
clasp in our previous example is
impossible to do with IDs since IDs are
supposed to be unique across the webpage
and each element can only have one ID
because of this I very rarely use IDs
and 99% of all my CSS I use class
selectors and avoid using HTML and ID
selectors as much as possible on top of
having many different selectors
CSS has multiple different ways to
combine selectors together to make your
selectors more specific the first way to
combine selectors is to specify multiple
selectors that an element must have in
order to be styled to do this you need
to write the various different selectors
together with no spacing between them
for example if you wanted to select all
h1 elements with the class large heading
then you would write the following
selector if you wanted to select an
element with the ID big blue and both
the class large and blue then you would
use this selector all HTML selectors can
be combined in this way as many times as
you want to create specific or general
rules another way to combine selectors
is to use multiple selectors to specify
an ancestor of an element to do this you
will put a space between the ancestor
and child selector for example to select
all P tags inside a div you simply need
to use the following selector this will
select all P tags that have a div as
their ancestor
even if the div tag is not the direct
parent of the P tag this combination of
selectors can be combined with the
previous combination of selectors to
make even more specific selectors for
example to select all h1 tags with the
class of brown to have a header with the
class main header as their ancestor you
would do this the last common
combination of selectors is when you
want to share a set of style properties
and values between multiple selectors if
you have a class big and another class
large that both have the same style
properties and values then you can
combine these selectors into one
selector by using a comma between the
selectors this allows you to avoid
duplication it is important to note that
all the CSS combination selectors can be
used together to create even more
complex combinations if needed there is
also one other form of selector the
everything selector that is used to
select every element on the entire
webpage this selector is defined as the
asterisk symbol and is only really used
to set some defaults for your entire web
page such as font family the last thing
we need to discuss before writing some
CSS is how to load the Styles we write
into our HTML page there are three main
ways to do this the first and by far
worst is to use inline Styles an inline
style is CSS that is written
inside an HTML element and thus does not
need a selector this is done through the
use of the style attribute this is a
terrible idea though says hTML is meant
for the content only and mixing CSS
styles into your HTML elements adds
presentation to your HTML which is meant
for CSS files it prevents us from
reusing those Styles anywhere else since
they are written into the actual HTML
element lastly depending on the Styles
you use an inline your page may load
slower the second option of using the
style HTML element is slightly better
but still a bad idea the style element
is an HTML element defined in the head
and formatted exactly like a CSS file
the problem with using the style element
though is that the presentation of the
web page is defined in the HTML file and
not a CSS file the Styles you define in
the style element are also only
available on the page you define them
and are thus not reusable across
multiple pages the final and best way to
define CSS Styles is to use a separate
CSS file and link to it from the HTML
all the styles for the entire webpage
can be find in one or more CSS files and
they can be added to any webpage by
using a simple link element inside the
head the link element is a simple
element that can be used to link files
to the HTML and its main use is to link
CSS files the link element is also an
empty element that uses the rel
attribute which stands for relationship
to define the relationship between the
linked file and the HTML document in the
case of CSS the rel attribute will be
style sheet since CSS is a style sheet
for the HTML the only other attribute
that we need to define is the href
attribute the href attribute works
exactly the same as the href attribute
of an anchor tag and should point to
either your CSS file or the URL of
another person's CSS file using external
CSS files like this is the best way to
use CSS
since it separates the presentation and
contents of websites and allows
reusability of styles across the website
now that we have an understanding of how
to write CSS Styles can select specific
HTML elements let's jump into a live
example of these concepts as you can see
on the Left I have a sample HTML page
with enough
Visual Studio code and on the right I
have this page opened up in Google
Chrome using live server to get started
let's use an inline style on this h1
element to turn the text a different
color so we'd use a style attribute here
and we would set the color value since
the color property is used to change
text color and we'll set it to a color
of red for example we save that as you
can see our text will change to red as
we know using these style attributes is
a bad idea instead let's use the style
tag inside of the head and use the h1
selector just like the h1 element and
we'll all set the color to blue this
time save that and we can see that color
is blue but again we know that this is
not the most optimal way to do it
instead let's create a new file called
styles.css inside the Styles dot CSS
file let's put our h1 selector and set
the color to green now in order to get
this style to load in our page we need
to use a link tag here which the rel is
going to be style sheet and the href is
going to point to that style CSS file
now if we say that you can see that our
text changes to green if we were to move
this link tag above our style tag for
example though you see that our text is
still blue this is because CSS takes
whatever the last define style is for an
element so in this case the h1 setting
the color to blue is below the import of
this link so our text is blue if we
remove this style though you'll see that
when we save it our text turns back to
green because it's loading this style on
here we can show that example again I
put an h1 here with a color of red this
time and now when we say that this text
will change to red because this selector
is after this selector now that we
finished importing all of our Styles
let's dive a little bit more into how
the Styles are actually applied so do
this let's add a class to this h1 and
we'll give it a class of blue instead of
our Styles dot CSS let's add that blue
class selector
here and give it a property value for
color to be blue now when we say that we
see that our color change to blue but
you would think that the color would be
green since this h1 selector comes after
the blue class selector but CSS actually
puts different values onto these
different selectors element selectors
are the lowest level selector which
means that they're always overridden by
other selectors such as the class
selector the class selector is then the
next in line and it is overridden only
by the ID selector so in order the ID
selector is the most important then the
class selector and then the element
selector so if we're to look at an
example we have an ID here class and
another class this selector would have a
higher specificity then this selector
that had three classes that is because
there's an ID here so the ID setting has
value of one and then we have two
classes here so the class value would
have two but this was three classes and
no ID so since there's one ID on this
one it would be a higher specificity so
anything in here would override anything
in here essentially the easiest way to
look at this is to first count the
number of IDs in the selector if the
number of IDs is equal then go on to the
number of classes in the selector if the
number of classes is equal then finally
go on to the number of elements in the
selector if that is also equal then
whichever one is defined last is going
to be the one that's applied in any case
if the ID number class number or element
number is greater when you get to that
stuff of adding that is the style that
will be applied also if we have an
inline style so for example in here if
we put style and we set that color to be
equal to black for example this will
override everything anything defined in
line like this overrides everything in
your stylesheet no matter what
most HTML elements have a set of default
CSS that is applied to them as you can
see the h1 tag over here has margin on
the top and bottom of it and this P tag
has this black text that is because the
text color is inherited from whatever
the parent is this is a parent if we
style the body tag in here and we set
the color to be red this will change all
the text in our entire application to be
red that is underneath the body tag
unless otherwise specified such as this
blue selector here that is specifying
the h1 should be blue this is because
the default value for text color is
inherit which means it inherits whatever
its parents probably it is since we've
been talking about color so much let's
dive into the different ways that you
can define colors in HTML by default you
can use these simple color selectors of
red green blue pink and various other
different colors but sometimes you want
to get more specific than these very
generic colors in order to do that we'll
use hexadecimal colors in order to set
these a hexadecimal number is some more
to our decimal system that goes from 0
to 9
but hexadecimal goes from 0 to 15 in
order to represent these numbers that
are above 9 hexadecimal uses the letters
ABCDE and F so if we wanted to write 15
in hexadecimal you would write the pound
sign followed by an F which would be 15
so for using colors this hexadecimal is
broken up into three distinct parts of
two digits each so we have the first two
digits the second two digits and the
third two digits and each side of these
digits represents a different color so
the first two digits represent red the
middle two digits represent green and
the last two digits represent blue and
this is on a scale from zero to double F
where double F is equal to 255 in
decimal so the smaller the number the
less of that we have so if this was zero
zero then that means there is no red at
all if this one was FF
it is that means that we have all the
most amount of blue possible so if we
wanted to get just blue we would use
zero zero for red zero zero for green
and then F F for blue and if we say that
we get a blue color this is a little bit
difficult to wrap your head around so
there's other ways to define colors in
CSS one of those ways is using RGB RGB
is just like the hexadecimal version but
it's broken out into three distinct
sections so we have red which goes
between 0 and 255 and this is in decimal
so we can just write 255 we want
entirely red and the next value is going
to be green again so we can just do 255
and then the last way is going to be
blue unless just say that's 0 so if we
save that we get yellow and then another
way if you wanted to have a partially
transparent color that you could use RGB
a where then we have one more value that
goes between 0 and 1 which is going to
be the transparency so if it's 1 it
means that it is fully opaque and if it
is 0 then it is going to be entirely
transparent and some combination in
between there means that it is partially
transparent this partial transparency
can also be achieved by using the
hexadecimal version of the color and we
will just have an extra two digits at
the end of the hexadecimal which
represents the transparency so if we
wanted to do black we would do 0 0 0 0 0
0 since we have 0 bread 0 green and 0
blue and then the final value will be
the alpha value which will be between 0
and 255 again so if we want it to be
entirely opaque we would do FF save that
when we get entirely opaque black and if
we wanted it to be entirely transparent
just 0 0 and that will make it entirely
transparent the last way to define color
is in HTML they're using HSL which
stands for huge saturation lightness the
first value hue goes between 0 and 360
and determines which color you're going
to be using will just use 0 on this
example saturation goes from 0 to 100%
and determines how colorful this color
is at 100% saturation it's as bright as
it can be and it's zero percent
saturation there is no color in it is
either going to be black white with
we're in between there so let's just use
100% in this example and then lastly
lightness is going to determine how
bright that color is so at 100%
lightness which is the max you're going
to have an entirely white color and at
0% lightness you're going to have an
entirely black color and anywhere in
between there is going to be a different
shade of that color so let's just use
50% in this example if we say that we
see that we get red from this also HSL
has an HSL a version which lets you put
the alpha value or the transparency the
end where one is going to be entirely
opaque and zero is going to be entirely
transparent just like RGB a at the top
next we're going to talk about the box
model in order to demonstrate this I'm
going to create a new div element and
I'm going to give it a class of a box
there we go and then in the style we'll
style that box the hood and we'll give
it a height and a width of 100 pixels a
padding of 20 pixels a margin of 50
pixels and a border that is going to be
10 pixels and as that will be black
don't worry about the syntax here this
is really just to demonstrate how the
box model works we saved that Oh first
let's give it a background background
color of red and now as you can see over
here we have this red background we have
our black border but where is this
margin and padding coming from in order
to see this let's inspect this element
in Google Chrome pull this over so that
we can actually see and down here we
have the box model so we have our
hundred width by 100 height which is the
actual content of our thing and then
around that we have a padding of 20 and
on the left here over here you can see
that it is highlighting so in blue we
have the actual content hundred by
hundred in orange we have the padding
which is 20 pixels on each side next
comes our black border which is ten
pixels around the padding and then
lastly our 50
was a margin that go around the content
and the box model works where the inside
of the box model the very center is your
actual content this is going to be your
text image whatever it is that takes up
that space is going to be there and then
the very next thing is padding padding
is essentially just spacing between your
content and your border so on a button
for example this is what allows you to
create space between your letters of
your button and the actual border around
your button with the background
background also goes on the padding
because the background is inside of the
border then we have the border which is
self-explanatory
whatever size you make the border is how
wide the border is going to be and then
lastly we have our margin which is going
to be the space on the outside of the
border which helps you space elements
out from each other
margin is meant to space elements around
other elements and padding is meant to
space elements around their own border
or to add spacing between the element
and their actual background now that we
understand the box model let's discuss
the various different units that we can
use on this box model let's close out of
this inspector widen up our view here
and let's talk about first of all pixels
pixels are fairly self-explanatory
they're the unit that you used most the
time when defining content sizes and is
going to be a set fixed width on every
sized screen the next unit we have is
percentage percentage is also fairly
self-explanatory and we'll take up
whatever percentage of the given width
that the object has inside of it spared
so if we make this with 10% this box
will be 10% of the width of the screen
since the entire width here is how much
space we have to work with a next type
of unit that we have is going to be am e
m is mostly used for fonts and font
related situations like padding around
fonts and it is going to be it scales
off of the actual font size so if your
font size is 16 pixels then one eemm
equals 16 pixels to e m would be 32
pixels and so on there's also another
type of font or scale called REM
which is very similar to e/m in that it
scales off of your font size but REM
scales off the font size of the root of
your document so the very very base
level of our browser where if we went
into the settings and scaled our font
size it would scale off of that while
e/m scales off of the parent so this box
has a parent of body so if we change the
font size on this body to be 20 pixels
you'll see that our actual box gets
wider but if we used re in here besides
the box stays the same even if we bump
this up to 200 pixels for example let's
do 30 actually as you can see from that
40 still doesn't change the size and
that right there is pretty much
everything you need to know in order to
get started with CSS
I know we've covered a lot in this video
and we're still missing a lot of what
there is to do in CSS but with these
simple rules you can get started and
create any basic website that you want
and style it using these CSS rules in my
next few videos I'm going to go and
cover all the CSS styling needed to
create a modern looking band website so
if you're interested in learning more
about CSS and the different properties
that are available be sure to check out
those videos when they come out also
like this video if you enjoyed it and
subscribe for more similar content and
let me know down in the comments below
why you decided you wanted to learn CSS
and what you're going to create with it
thanks for watching